[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christin du übernimmst
später wieder den sportlichen Teil der
Sendung ja Frust und Freude im Fußball
guten Abend hier sind unsere
Themen bewegendes gedenken im Bundestag
appellieren Zeitzeugen das Vermächtnis
der Holocaustopfer zu
bewahren
dann lasse ich ihn diesen Satz hier sei
ein Mensch sei ein
Mensch nicht genug Munition die
Europäische Union kann ihre
Lieferzusagen für die Ukraine nicht
einhalten und hohe handelshörden 4er
Jahre nach dem brexit beklagt die
Wirtschaft immer mehr lästige
Kontrollen es war heute kein Tag wie
jeder andere im Bundestag das Parlament
gedachte der Befreiung des
Vernichtungslagers Auschwitz und der
Opfer der scho zwei Gäste erinnerten in
eindringlichen Reden an die Schrecken
und Unbegreiflichkeit des Holocaust und
berührten damit nicht nur die
Abgeordneten über die außergewöhnliche
Gedenkveranstaltung berichtet Andreas
Huppert der Bundestag erhebt sich
Applaus für eine Holocaust Überlebende
für ihre Rede und für ihr Engagement GEG
das Vergessen Eva 91 Jahre alt überlebt
Auschwitz sie ert sich an den Tag vor
fast 80 Jahren getrennt von der Familie
12 Jahre alt wird sie ins
Konzentrationslager deportiert damalste
ich nicht dass meine Mama und mein
siebenjähriger Bruder
Thomas bereits vier Monate vorher dort
angekommen und direkt nach der ank
Verg
W als eines von nur ganz ganz wenigen
Kindern entkommt sie der Schoa überlebt
den Massenmord wird von Sowjetsoldaten
befreit ihr Appell ist eindringlich nie
wieder sei
jetzt begann nicht mit
Auschwitz sie begann mit
Worten sie begann mit dem Schweigen und
dem wegschauen der
dies gelte auch für heute besonders nach
dem hamasangriff auf Israel im letzten
Oktober Antisemitismus habe aller Orts
wieder
zugenommen der Sportjournalist Marcel
Reif ist ebenfalls Gastredner in diesem
Jahr sein Vater überlebt in Holocaust
der Großteil der Familie wird ermordet
reif hat seinen Vater nie über das
Erlebte reden hören er habe seinem Sohn
aus dieser dunklen Vergangenheit
lediglich einen Satz eine Lehre
mitgegeben dann lass ich ihn den kleinen
undch großartigen wundervollen Satz den
mein Vater Leon reif gesagt hat dann
lasse ich ihn diesen Satz hier seier
Mensch sei ein
Mensch Holocaust gedenken zwei reden die
die Vergangenheit lebendig werden lassen
und die die Gegenwart mahnen alles zu
tun damit Geschichte sich nicht
wiederholt nach dem Gedenken und einer
Pause krt der Alltag ins Parlament
zurück mit der Generaldebatte zu den
Haushaltsberatungen obwohl so alltäglich
war es auch wieder nicht wann hat man
den Kanzler schon mal sagen hören sie
sind eine Mimose Herr März auch damit
reagierte der Regierungschef auf die
Kritik des Oppositionsführers das und
mehr jetzt im Bericht von Britta
Bucholz der Moment in dem Olaf Scholz im
Feuer steht normalerweise heute schlägt
Oppositionsführer März zumeist einen
anderen Ton an sein pldoer die
französische Freundschaft Stärken
Wirtschaftsprobleme lösen den Kanzler
erwähnt er namentlich nicht dessen
Partei schon sie waren einmal die Partei
der ArbeiterInnen und Arbeit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
sind heute eine Partei der
subventionierten Arbeitslosigkeit
geworden und nicht mehr eine Partei der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
stattdessen der Kanzler ungewöhnlich
kämpferisch mehrmals greift der März
persönlich an wirft ihm den Abbruch der
Gespräche zur gemeinsamen
Migrationspolitik vor so eine
hasenfüßigkeit vor der eigenen
Verantwortung davon laufen das habe ich
noch nicht erlebt Herr März so viel
feikeit vor der eigenen kurage habe ich
noch nie
gesehen alle Fraktionen verschärfen den
Ton gegenüber der AFD Scholz um März
sehen sie als Gefahr für Deutschland
Weidel wiederum meint die Ampel ruiniere
das Land und
sie können Deutschland nicht gut
regieren und sie wollen es nicht sie
richten es zu Grunde und ich sag ihn
auch
warum weil sie ihr eigenes Land weil sie
Deutschland hassen diese Regierung hast
Deutschland wie viel Verachtung wie viel
Menschenfeindlichkeit wie viel
Gefährlichkeit und wie viel
verächtlichmung demratischer
Institutionen waren hier gerade in 10
Minuten zu
hören im Kampf gegen Rechts sind sich
fast alle einig eine weitere
Zusammenarbeit mit der Ampel schließt
Friedrich März allerdings
aus lange gab es hitzige Diskussion
jetzt ist es offiziell bundesweit soll
eine Bezahlkarte für Asylbewerber kommen
alleinstehende Bewerber erhalten gerade
460 € bar ausgezahlt bekommen sie aber
meist weniger weil etwa essen oder
Kleidung gestellt werden mit der
Bezahlkarte sollen die geflüchteten
ähnlich wie mit einer EC-Karte einkaufen
können Überweisung soll damit nicht
möglich sein mehr jetzt von Patrick
müting guten Morgen erinder Latza aus
Albanien bekommt ihre Bezahlkarte statt
nur Bargeld was in Zukunft für alle
Asylbewerberinnen und Asylbewerber
funktionieren soll wird unter anderem im
Landkreis eigsfeld in Thüringen bereits
getestet für sie eine Erleichterung im
Alter
ich habe ein Problem mit den Zahlen auf
Deutsch für mich ist es damit
einfacher die Karte funktioniert wie
eine Guthabenkarte einkaufen geht wo
Kartenzahlung akzeptiert wird allerdings
beschränkt auf den Landkreis und
ausgewählte Regionen im Umland was nicht
funktioniert Überweisungen im Innen und
Ausland sowie Auszahlungen so ähnlich
soll es auch bundesweit eingeführt
werden aus meiner Sicht wird die Karte
wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Beitrag dazu
sein die Anreiz zu senken B den
Missbrauch zu verhindern und B
insbesondere das schleuserwesens zu
stoppen im eigsfeld soll das Modell
zusätzlich zum Arbeiten anregen wer
einen Job annimmt bekommt die ihm noch
zustehenden Leistungen wieder in bar
ausgezahlt hat mehr Freiheiten das zeige
Wirkung sagt der Landrat unsere
Erfahrungen belegen dass 17 Flüchtlinge
als geduldete dennoch sofort Arbeit
aufgenommen haben der Thüringer
Flüchtlingsrat iert die Pilotprojekte
kein Bargeld oder richtiges Bankkonto
führe zu zu vielen Einschränkungen im
Alltag ab Sommer sollen die Bezahlkarten
bundesweit eingeführt
werden wie funktioniert die Bezahlkarte
für Flüchtlinge und was kann sie bringen
in unserer ZF heute App haben wir unter
anderem bisherige Erfahrungen und
Einschätzungen von Experten für Sie
zusammengefasst der frühere
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Marsen ist
selbst ins Visier seiner ehemaligen
Behörde geraten der Verfassungsschutz
soll Maßen als Rechtsextremisten
gespeichert haben nach ZDF Informationen
liegt eine umfangreiche Materialsammlung
zu Marsen vor er selbst sei bereits vor
zwei Wochen informiert worden Marsen hat
vor wenigen Tagen seinen Austritt aus
der CDU erklärt und will mit der
werteunion eine Partei
gründen die Inflation ist zu
Jahresbeginn deutlich zurückgegangen im
Januar sind die Verbraucherpreise nach
vorläufigen Daten nur noch um 2,9%
gestiegen das ist der niedrigste Wert
seit zweieinhalb Jahren teilte das
Statistische Bundesamt mit Preistreiber
bleiben Lebensmittel die Energiekosten
sind dagegen
gesunken statt zugesagter ein Million
Geschosse für die Ukraine bis Ende März
wird voraussichtlich nur gut die Hälfte
geliefert werden dieses eucheeitern hat
der EU Außenbeauftragte Borell heute am
Rande des verteidigungsministertreffens
in Brüssel eingestanden darüber und wie
man die Ukraine weiter unterstützen kann
wurde dort beraten mehr von Ulf
Röller die Ukraine übt die Verteidigung
gegen einen möglichen Angriff aus
Belarus sie will ihre Kampfbereitschaft
zeigen aber in der Realität ist die Lage
schwierig eine Million Geschosse hat die
EU der Ukraine bis zum März versprochen
aber sie kann ihr Versprechen nicht
einhalten das neue Datum Ende des
Jahres es ist wahr die Ukraine braucht
mehr Unterstützung das ist eine
Botschaft an alle EU-Länder wir müssen
mehr Waffen liefern und mehr Munition
liefern und wir müssen schneller liefern
denn der Krieg an der Front ist
brutal Krisentreffen der
Verteidigungsminister in Brüssel sie
kündigen für das laufende Jahr insgesamt
21 Milliarden Euro an Waffenhilfe an
vorher hatten in einem Brandbrief der
deutsche Bundeskanzler und vier weitere
EU Regierungschefs ihre Kollegen
aufgefordert mehr zu tun deutschland ist
nach den USA der zweitwichtigste
Unterstützer der Ukraine abgeschlagen
Italien und
Frankreich schnelle Hilfe ist für die
Ukraine entscheidend denn die Kämpfe
sind intensiv und wir müssen Putin
zeigen dass er nicht den längeren Atem
hat wir werden die Ukraine ausreichend
unterstützen Europa wirkt ein wenig
kriegsmüde die Gefahr besteht dass die
Ukraine nicht das bekommt was sie
braucht diese Sorge schreibt unter
anderem den Bundeskanzler um morgen auf
dem Sondergipfel müssen die
eureierungschefs beweisen dass sie zur
Ukraine stehen denn die ukrainischen
Soldaten an der Front brauchen Waffen
und Munition um den Krieg nicht zu
verlieren schauen wir in den
Gazastreifen knapp vier Monate nach
Beginn des Krieges soll dort mindestens
die Hälfte aller Gebäude beschädigt oder
zerstört sein das berichtet die
britische BBC sie hat für ihre Recherche
Satellitenbilder verglichen wie diese
aus Hanan Junis im Süden mindestens
144 000 Gebäude sollen insgesamt
betroffen sein andere satellitenbinder
zeigen wie sich Flüchtlinge an
vermeintlich sicheren Orten sammeln
Volker dutcheck berichtet Tod und neues
Leben dicht beieinander während Israels
Soldaten in Gaza angreifen bringen
palästinensische Frauen wie basma shamam
le Babys auf die Welt alle 10 Minuten
ein sagt uniceef viele Mütter im
Gazastreifen sind nur wenige Tage in der
Klinik danach muss das Bett geräumt
werden ich habe das Krankenhaus schon
nach zwei Stunden verlassen das war
nicht lang genug der Arzt hat mich und
mein Baby nur einmal untersucht auch
dieser Angriff Israels am frühen
dienstagmgen war gezielt diesmal im
Westjordanland ein Krankenhaus in Genin
was viele entsetzt die israelischen
Spezialkräfte kommen verkleidet ins
Hospital mit einem Maxi cososi unterm
Arm getant als muslimische Frau mit
Schleier am Ende sind drei Männer
tot Israel leugnet die Tötung nicht die
drei seinen Extremisten gewesen hätten
sich im Krankenhaus versteckt um
Anschläge zu planen sagt die
Armee zunehm drücken die Vereinten
Nationen in den Fokus der Kritik vor
allem seitdem es Vorwürfe gibt
Mitarbeiter der
unhilfsorganisation unwahr sein am
Terror der Hammers beteiligt dass
Deutschland und die USA ihre Hilfe
ausgesetzt hätten seine Katastrophe
sagen unwahr
Mitarbeiter wir sind die größte
Hilfsorganisation in der Region die
Menschen können nicht ohne uns leben
denn dann fehlen tausende Dienstleistung
der Gesundheitsvorsorge und der
Logistik Israels Armee bestätigt am
Abend erstmals hamasunnel in Gaza
geflutet zu haben ziel sei es die
unterirdische
terrorinfrastruktur zu zerstören hieß
es zurück nach Deutschland wo es heute
frische Zahlen vom Arbeitsmarkt gibt und
wie zu Beginn eines Jahres üblich ist
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen gestiegen
285000 waren laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit auf Jobsuche das sind
169 000 mehr als im Dezember die Quote
stieg auf
6,1% gegenüber dem Januar des Vorjahres
stieg die Zahl der Arbeitslosen um
9000 dabei fehlen Fachkräfte an allen
Ecken und Enden unternehmen müssen sich
jedenfalls jede Menge einfallen lassen
um neues Personal zu gewinnen inkten
Klinge serkn schelig ist der erste
Lademeister am Frankfurter Flughafen der
seine Ausbildung in 11 Monaten
absolvieren konnte er ist gerade fertig
geworden früher dauerte es mehrere Jahre
um diesen Beruf ausüben zu können hat
sich eine riesentür ziemlich geöffnet ja
ist eine hohe Herausforderung ja ich
werde mein Bestes dafür geben aber ich
bin auch sehr stolz darauf schnellere
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten sind ein Versuch
um Mitarbeiter zu gewinnen während der
coronakrise mussten 4000 Beschäftigte
gehen jetzt braucht der Flughafen rund
3000 neue Mitarbeitende pro Jahr um etwa
ausscheidende zu ersetzen ein
deutschlandticket für alle und eine
Prämie für diejenigen die jemanden
anwerben sollen helfen der Arbeitsmarkt
ist einfach eng und wenn Bewerber die
Wahl haben dann suchen sie sich eben
auch ihren Arbeitgeber ganz gezielt aus
früher war alleine ein guter Name als
Arbeitgeber ausreichend und die Bewerber
kmen und heute muss man sich als
Unternehmen um die Bewerber aktiv
bemühen laut der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit gibt es inzwischen in jedem
sechsten Beruf Engpässe
Arbeitsmarktexperte Enzo Weber sagt
Unternehmen stehen in einem intensiven
Wettbewerb die Unternehmen müssen
konkurrieren um die Arbeitskräfte das
heißt Sie müssen dann auch mehr anbieten
und das nicht nur beim Lohn sondern es
geht auch um Arbeitsbedingungen um
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten im Job um
flexible Arbeitszeiten oder auch
mobilarbeit im Fall von Serkan schelig
hat es geklappt einen neuen Mitarbeiter
zu gewinnen er möchte am Flughafen
bleiben und gerne weitere
Aufstiegschancen
nutzen jetzt zu einem Jubiläum das viele
Briten nicht unbedingt in Feierlaune
bringt vier Jahre brexit am 31 Januar
2020 verließ das Vereinigte Königreich
die EUR euräische Union und damit auch
den EU Binnenmarkt seitdem sind
Lebensmittel teurer geworden und die
Armut im Land ist gestiegen auch die
Einwanderungszahlen gingen deutlich hoch
und inzwischen halten gut 60% der Briten
den brexit für einen Misserfolg und neue
Grenzkontrollen für Lebensmittel ab
heute dürften die Probleme weiter
verschärfen Hilke
Petersen vor dem Parlament in London
protestieren brexit Gegner seit Jahren
drehen die Europahymne auf wenn der
Premierminister
vorbeifährt die Hälfte aller
Lebensmittel für die Briten muss
importiert werden vieles aus der EU im
fairhafen von Dover gelten jetzt neue
Zollvorschriften heißt zusätzliche
Formulare und Checks hinter der Grenze
ab April für tierische Produkte Gemüse
Pflanzen die Großhändler müssen waren
mühsam nach Risikoklassen sortieren 385
Millionen Euro zusätzlich dürfte das
alles kosten
es scheint immer nur mit Versuch und
Irrtum zu gehen ich stelle mich auf
Verzögerungen und höhere Kosten
ein also für uns gibt es keinen
wirklichen Vorteil seit dem brexit eine
Studie des Londoner Bürgermeisters
rechnet vor 2 Millionen Jobs weniger
quer durchs Land und viele britische
Bürger sind ärmer im Durchschnitt um
mehr als 2000 € im vergangenen Jahr weil
brexit ihre Kosten
hochtreibt die gestiegenen
Lebensmittelpreise belasten die Leute am
meisten macht die Lebenshaltungskosten
insgesamt total
unerträglich brexit hat sich nicht als
das erwiesen was sie angepriesen hatten
das ist ärgerlich denn es wird dem Land
langfristig
[Musik]
schaden bei der wöchentlichen
Fragestunde mit dem Premierminister
heute kein Wort zum brexit Jubiläum das
Thema nervt jede Partei im Wahljahr also
besser
verschween so jetzt zum Sport und schwer
enttäuschten Fußballerinnen vom FC
Bayern München erstmalig kein deutscher
Verein im Viertelfinale der Königsklasse
zweimal geführt und dann entschied auch
noch ein Eigentor das aus der Frauen des
FC Bayern München im letzten
Gruppenspiel der Champions League 2:2
gegen Paris Saint-Germain ein Sieg hätte
den Einzug in die kopase
gesichert die bayernfrauen fassungslos
und entsetzt nach einem Spiel das
unglücklicher nicht hätte laufen können
wir sind alle echt richtig enttäuscht
ich glaub weil wir uns so viel erhofft
und e gesagt haben komm wir wir legen
alles in dieses Spiel Julia Gin und
Sydney lohann hatten die Bayern zweimal
in Führung gebracht ausgerechnet ein
Eigentor von Georgia stanway beendete in
der 88 spielminute die
viertelfinalträume der
Münchnerinnen ja Jubel bei Fortuna
Düsseldorf der zweitliggist steht nach
28 Jahren endlich wieder im Halbfinale
des DFB Pokals der Männer durch das 6 Z5
nach Meter Schießen beim FC St Pauli am
Boden zerstört ST paulis Marcel Hartel
gleich dreimal darf zum Meter Punkt
schreiten nur einmal trifft er zum ein
zu ein im 11mer Krimi nach 120
Spielminuten Versagen ihm dann die
Nerven Fortuna Torwart kastmeer hat sich
aber zu früh von der Linie bewegt hatel
darf wiederholen und wählt nun die
andere
Ecke irgendwann muss er wieder deine
Ecke nehmen und ja den Braten hab ich
ochen Fortunas Grieche Christos zollis
bleibt dann cool ein frecher Schlenzer
Düsseldorf im Halbfinale Trainer tune
war mit der Art der Ausführung nicht
einverstanden wählt lieber tard
kastenmeer für einen
gratulationskuss Deutschlands bester
Tennisspieler Alexander SF hat seine
Teilnahme an der Davis Cup Qualifikation
gegen Ungarn am Wochenende wegen eines
Infekts abgesagt für ihn rückt
Maximilian mater
nach Speed klettern eine Disziplin die
erstmalig bei den nationalen Special
Olympics ausgetragen wird den Spielen
für Menschen mit geistiger
Beeinträchtigung lokalmadorin Alexandra
Katsch bewältigte in Weimar die speziell
geschraubte Route am schnellsten und
sagte im Anschluss ich bin total
glücklich ich finde so soll es sein
danke schön Christin wir haben zum
Schluss noch einen der berühmtesten
Gitarristen der Welt für
Sie das ist Mar Knopfler mit seiner Band
di stras wurde eher zur
Rocklegende jetzt versteigert der
74-Jährige seine Gitarrensammlung eine
ging vor wenigen Stunden für umgerechnet
rund 700 000 € über den Tisch ein Teil
des Geldes soll an wohltätige Zwecke
gehen und mit dem Rest will Knopfler
sich ein paar neue Gitarren
kaufen dafür bräucht dann wahrscheinlich
neues Haus so hier gibt's noch die
Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto und die gehen
so 11 24 28 29 40 43 Superzahl 7 weitere
Infos und Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZF Text auf Seite
557 heute Nacht und morgen überquert uns
ein Regenband mehr zum milden
winterwettergleich von Katja horneffer
um
21:45 gibt es das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka von uns für Sie einen
entspannten Abend und bis bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend diese eindrucksvolle
tiefdruckspirale brachte heute schon
orkanböhnen über der Nordsee mit mit
mehr als 150 km pro Stunde und heute
Nacht so zwischen tronheim und BDE
können durchaus Windgeschwindigkeiten an
die z 100 km pro Stunde erreicht werden
in Orkanböhen ein bisschen was bekommen
wir von der wolkenspirale auch ab
nämlich dieses Wolkenband das bringt bei
uns aber doch im Wesentlichen nur Regen
mit und so regnet es heute Nacht
zwischen der Mosel und der Ostsee in
Bayern ist es dagegen zum Teil klar und
dort wird es dann auch am kältesten da
sinken die Werte auf + 3 bis -1° sonst
bleibt die Nacht bei 7 bis 3° milder und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
recht einheitlich in Deutschland
zwischen 6 und 11° am Vormittag kann es
in der Mitte und im Süden noch länger
trüb sein mit Regen im Norden lockern
die Wolken dagegen schon auf bei einem
starken bis stürmischen Wind aus
westlichen Richtungen an der Ostsee dort
kann es dann am Nachmittag für einige
Regenschauer reichen sonst wird das ein
freundlicher Nachmittag und nur am
oberrehein und im Alpen Vorland bleibt
es noch länger trüb mit Regen in den
nächsten Tagen geht es wechselhaft
weiter und es bleibt auch recht mild bei
Höchstwerten von 4 bis 13° ich wünsche
ih noch einen schönen Abend